[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم مشاهدي قناه
الجزيره والجزيره مباشر مصر
نقلت وكاله الانباء المصريه الرسميه عن
مصدر امني قوله ان تفجيرات عصر الجمعه في
سيناء نفذتها مروحيه مصريه ضد من وصفهم
بانهم الجهاديون كانوا يحاولون اطلاق
الصواريخ باتجاه الاراضي المصريه كانت
جماعه جهاديه و مصادر اسرائيليه وامريكيه
قد قالت ان الغاره على سيناء نفذتها طائره
اسرائيليه بدون طيار نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقشه في محور
الى اي حد جاءت توضيحات الجيش المصري بشان
عمليه سيناء كافيه لحسم الجدل الذي دار
حولها فكيف ستنعكس هذه الحادثه وما رافقها
من لغط على الاوضاع الامنيه والسياسيه في
مصر
بعد نحو اربع وعشرين ساعه من وقوع انفجار
في سيناء وعدا المتحدث باسم الجيش المصري
بالتحقق من اسبابه ونقلت وكاله الانباء
المصريه الرسميه عن مصدر امني قوله ان
الانفجار نجم عن غاره نفذتها مروحيه مصريه
ضد مجموعه جهاديه قال انها كانت تحاول
اطلاق صواريخ باتجاه الاراضي المصريه من
ناحيتها قالت جماعه تطلق على نفسها اسم
مجاهدي بيت المقدس ان القتلى من عناصرها
وان طائره اسرائيليه من دون طيار هي التي
نفذت الغاره ضدهم
جلسه قتلى غاره اختلف المصريون ال منقسمون
الى فريقين عن الجهه التي نفذتها ال قتل
مسلحون جهاديون في شمال سيناء ينتمون حسب
بيان على مواقع جهاديه الى جماعه انصار
بيت المقدس سقطوا في غاره جويه عصر الجمعه
تقول الجماعات ان طائره اسرائيليه بدون
طيار نفذت الهجوم بينما كان 5 جهاديين
يصبون صواريخ لضرب اسر ائيل قتل منهم
اربعه وجه قائد العمليه وفق روايه
الجماعات المسلحه نفى الجيش المصري هذه
الروايه جمله وتفصيلا واكد مصدر امني بعد
يوم من الغموض ان مروحيه مصريه نفذت
الغاره التي استهدفت جهاديين كانوا
يستعدون لاطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه الاراضي
المصريه وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش اوضح في
وقت سابق انه سمع دوي انفجارين غرب خط
الحدود الدوليه مع اسرائيل وتحديدا على
بعد ثلاثه كيلومترات بمنطقه العشره واضاف
ان عناصر القوات المسلحه نشطت المنطقه
المحيطه بموقع الانفجار
للوقوف على اسباب الحادث لوجود لاي تنسيق
او تعاون امني بين تل ابيب والقاهره ختم
المتحدث باسم الجيش المصري تصريحاته التزم
الترابي بالصمت بيد ان مصادر اعلاميه
اسرائيليه غير رسميه تبنت روايه تشن طائره
اسرائيليه بدون طيار الغاره المثيره للجدل
من يزيد الروايه مختلفتين تعقيدا هو اغلاق
اسرائيل مطار ايلات يوم الخميس عده ساعات
لاسباب امنيه ولا شك ان الوضع الامني غير
المستقر في شمال سيناء استاذ تدهورا منذ
عزل الجيش الرئيس محمد مرسي في الثالث من
يوليو الماضي فقد استهدفت جماعات مسلحه
قوات الامن والمقار الامنيه اكثر من مره
ما ادى الى مقتل عشرات الجنود المصريين
وكان الجيش ارسال تعزيزات الى المنطقه
ويكون حتى اللحظه بعمليات عسكريه تستهدف
المسلحين وفق الجيش قتل يوم الاربعاء ما
لا يقل عن ستين مسلحا الاختلاف بشان ما
حدث في العشره هو جزء من مشهد يصير فيه
المصريون على ان لا يتفقوا الان حتى عندما
يتعلق الامر بمساله حتى
لمزيد من التوضيح بشان رؤيه الجانب
الاسرائيلي لغاره عصر الجمعه في سيناء
ينضم الينا من تل ابيب سيديال عليما
المحلل العسكري في راديو اسرائيل سيد يا
مرحبا بك اولا ماذا يعني امتناع الجيش
الاسرائيلي عن تبني اولا في هذه الغاره
التي وقعت في سيناء
في الواقع اه الناطق العسكري اه اه التزم
الجانب السلطه منذ النشره الان ب اه
الاوليه حول هذا الموضوع ولكن لسان اه اه
التعقيب اه للناطق العسكري اه اه كانت ان
اه الجيش الاسرائيلي لا ينفي ولا يؤكد هذه
الانباء لذلك ب لهذا السبب الساده
الاعتقاد والافتراض ربما اه لدى الصحفيين
والمحللين في اسرائيل ان اه النشره من
انباء وان اه الطائره بدون طيار اسرائيليه
قد نفذت هذه الغاره اه اه ربما اه تكون
صحيحه لان لم يصدر نفى واضح من الجانب
الاسرائيلي من الجانب الثاني لم يصدر في
مصر
الاسئله بهذه
او تبني المسؤوليه عن هذه العمليه البيان
الذي اشرتم اليه جاء متاخرا اه ولذلك اه
الاعتقاد كان بان اسرائيل فعلا او سلاح
الجو الاسرائيلي فعلا يقف وراء هذه
العمليه
ووفقا الاساليب المتبعه اه للجيش
الاسرائيلي عندما يقوم بعمليات دون ان
يريد التحمل اني المسؤوليه عن ذلك لا ينفي
ولا يؤكد ويلتزم جانب وهكذا ساد الاعتقاد
هذه المره ايضا ان الحاله كانت كذلك هل
هناك اي علاقه بين الغاره التي حدثت في
سيناء و اغلاق مطار ايلات بصوره مؤقته في
اليوم الذي سبق تلك الغاره وفقا لما سمته
السلطات الاسرائيليه اسباب امنيه
بلا شك في الواقع خلال الاسابيع الاخيره
ان نرى ان هناك اه نوع من اه اه الجاهزيه
في القوات المرابطه في منطقه الحدود مع
مصر اسرائيل اه اه نصرت قبه القبه منظومه
القبه الحديديه اه قبل حوالي اسبوعين
وبالتالي جاءت هذه الانباء حول ان طرات
ادت الى اغلاق اه اه مطار اه ايلات بناء
على ذلك كان او ساد الاعتقاد بان هناك اه
معلومات حول نيه او انذارات مؤكده ومعينه
لاطلاق الصواريخ او تنفيذ اي عمليه ضد
اسرائيل وبالتالي جاءت هذه الغاره بشكل اه
منطقي وطبيعي ربما نستطيع القول اه كان اه
من الواضح ان اه ال السلاح الجوي
الاسرائيلي يقف وراء هذه العمليه وخاصه لم
تصدر هناك اي ايضاحات اخرى من الجانب
المصري البيان الرسمي الصادر عن المتحدثه
العسكريه المصري بالامس اشار الى انه في
هذه المرحله ليس هناك اي مستوى من مستويات
التنسيق بين القوات المسلحه المصريه
ونظيرتها الاسرائيليه بينما اه اه في بعض
الصحف الاسرائيليه مثل ها ارتز نقلت عن
مسؤولين امنيين اسرائيليين ان التنسيق على
افضل ما يكون ما هي الحقيقه في هذا الصدد
الحقيقه ان هناك اه اه تنسيقا مستمرا بين
اه اسرائيل ومصر وخاصه بين المستويين اه
العسكريين في اسرائيل و اه مصر واه في
الواقع من الجانب الثاني المستوى العسكري
يدرك جيدا ان هذا الموضوع يثير نوع من
الارتباك في مصر ولذلك هناك بشكل دائم
ومستمر محاوله لاخفاء او عدم اه اه اعطاء
او القاء الضوء على هذا التنسيق القائمه
بين الطرفين ولكن لا شك ان هناك تنسيق اه
مستمره يومي بين الطرفين وخاصه ان هناك
مصالح مشتركه لاسرائيل ومن خاصه في هذه
الظروف السيد الى العليم الخبير العسكري
اللي راديو اسرائيل شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
المشاركه
موضوع حلقتنا مشاهدينا الاعزاء لمناقشه مع
ضيفينا من القاهره اللواء محمود زاهر
الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
ومن القاهره ايضا اللواء اركان حرب
المتقاعد عبد الحميد عمران المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بكما والسؤال سياده
اللواء محمود زاهر سياده اللواء هل
التوضيحات الصادره عن القوات المسلحه في
عمليه حساسه كهذه في ظروف حساسه كهذه
كافيه برايك
اولا بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم تحياتي ليك
يا استاذ محمود طيبين اه بالامس الساعه
عشره ونص تحديدا كنت على القناه الاسميه
للتلفزيون المصري واعلنت ان استهداف موقع
الارهابيين كان من خلال قوات المصري هذا
ربما كان بخلاف ما تم من اعلان رسميه
واحترام لي اه نمره اثنين اسقاط اعلى كلمه
الطائره بدون طيار علينا نعرفه علميا
الطائره بدون طيار مهمتها الاساسيه اما
استطلاع او اذا استعملت في عمليات قصف
تستعمل في حالتين اما القصف العشوائي
القصف هدف ثابت معلوم الاحداثيات ليس لها
احتمال من لانها تبقى عباره عن الطياره
يعني عباره عن البرمجه الالكترونيه اما
بالنسبه الحادث امس لا تستطيع طائره بدون
طيار
ان تستهدف هدف متحرك على عدل ينصب وبعد
دقائق وثواني ينصرف وهو كان مجموعه
الارهابيين التي تستهدف اسرائيل خمسه
صواريخ وقامت القوات المصريه
باستهداف هذا الواضح واللي قاله المتحده
الثاني من انه سيبحث الامر واه
تداعياته كانت تركز حوالين عدد القتلى
لانه مش خمسه بس الجهه اللي انتم اليها
كيف وصلوا الى هذا المكان ما يمكن ان
يترتب على هذا من اه تحصيل معلومات
وتنسيقها ثم اعداد الخطوه القادمه بالنسبه
للقوات المصريه اما بالنسبه للتنسيق بين
وزاره الدفاع المصريه ووزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه المستوى العسكري وفي اطار اه
اتفاقيه السلام نعم هناك تنسيق وهناك
تبادل معلومات
ولكن هذا لا ينفي ان المصدر الرسمي
الاسرائيلي حينما يقول انه لا ينفي ولا
يؤكد ما اعتقدش اللي في اه جهاز استخبارات
ياتي اه
نجاح في هدف يرفضه وهذا من حقه اما ما
اقول لحضرتك حتى الان هو الحقيقه سياده
اللواء عبد الحميد عمران من الناحيه
العمليه هل فعلا الطائرات ال اه بدون لا
تستطيع ان تنفذ عمليات هذه منصه صواريخ
منصوبه لاطلاق الصواريخ باتجاه اسرائيل اه
اه اه والروايه التي ذكرتها وسائل الاعلام
العالميه ووكالات الانباء اشارت الى ان
الطائرات بدون طيار استهدفت هذه المنصب
[موسيقى]
هذا غير صحيح طبعا لان لوحدك تذكر جميع ال
ال
قاده حماس الذين استهدفوا في غزه كانوا
يركبون السيارات او مشكلات وتم استهدافهم
متحركين
طبعا ان تستخدم وعندما نوبيل تعالى تستطيع
اكثر من طائرات الاباتشي للخطه انها تناول
روايه في الجو وتوضع صواريخها الى اهدافهم
تحريك كثيره لحظات اللي صار احنا الموضوع
بدا بان رويترز الطالب عن الحدث وت نسبه
الى خمس مصادر امنيه في سيناء ياتي هذا
الكلام
مباشره في هذا الكلام كلام
واحنا سمعنا انفجارين ومع اثنين دوريات شو
فعل مفكرين دور اللي حصل
لا اقول هذا الكلام انه ال ال انه يحاول
ان بعض التصريحات العمل الصعيد النداء
تماما في نطاق التعاون بالجيش المصري ليست
سعيده وان الطياره هي ال ال ال الم تحركها
لضرب اه يعود المتحدث الرسمي المصري ويكون
لهم ه هو نفس ان تكون طائره اسرائيليه قد
اخترقت المجال الجوي المصري كما ايضا يكون
كلهم نفى وجود اي تنسيق او تعاون بين
الجيش المصري وباسم الاسرائيلي واضح من
الكلام بانه الهدف دعوه هدف داخلي في مصر
وليس الهدف هو اسرائيل او الهدف الفلسطيني
او
اه
استمر
انا انا انا استمع اليك لو لو كنت فرق من
هذا ال هذه المداخله دعني اطرح دعني اطرح
السؤال على حضرتك فيه
تفضل
لا تستطيع ال ال الطائره البريتور او ال
او انها حتى مفترض معك الحدود الاسرائيليه
ويفترض ان المتحدث المصري صادق بنسبه
خمسين في المائه الكلام تستطيع وهي داخل
الحدود الاسرائيليه ان تطلق الصواريخ
بتاعتها على المكان اللي
دون ان تجتاز الحدود المصريه يعني الكلام
تصحيح وهزم الصحيح لكن السياق كيف وانت
متحدث عسكري تتحدث باسم الجيش المصري احنا
سمعنا ومن الراضي اللبس الشرعي والان
سمعنا مفضلين وعدتنا دوريات شوف بعيد لو
كان كلامك الذي ذكرته بعد اربعه وعشرين
ساعه حقيقيا كنت من اول لحظه قلت الذي
طائره مصريه استهدفت من اطلاق صواريخ و اه
اه اه ان احنا اطلقنا عليهم اللي صار
لكن هذا لم يتم الى بعد اربعه وعشرين ساعه
واضح ان بعد ترتيب الاوراق وبعد مشاورات
وبعد محاوله اخراج سيناريو وهذا
اللواء هل يعقل ان تنطلق الطائرات
الاباتشي المصريه وتنفذ غرض من هذا القبيل
دون علم القوات المسلحه بها او المتحدث
الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه بين
لا يعني استاذ محمود كلاما غير موجود ولكن
دعني اصحح اه يعني معلومه الها سياده
اللواء حميد ما كان يستهدف في قطاع غزه من
طائرات كان بيتم من خلال
والطائرات الحربيه وليست الطائرات بدون
طيار على الاطلاق يعني الطائرات بدون طيار
زي ما قلت لحضرتك بيطلع بنوع من البرمجه
الالكترونيه حتى لو كان هناك سيطره ارضيه
لا تستطيع ان تتحمل حادث مثل هذه معلومه
اخرى لا بد ان نعلم ان التعدي الحدود بين
اسرائيل ومصر له تداعيات كثيره
ولا يمكن ان يحدث هذا وحتى الان لم يحدث
عمره ثلاثه الصواريخ كانت موجهه
اه اسرائيل وليس
اربعه ما حدث فعلا هو استهداف للموقع من
خلال قوات مصريه وانا اعلنت هذا الساعه
ونص بالليل اذا كان هناك يمكن ان يقال او
يحب الله عبد الحميد يوجه اليوم للمتحدث
العسكري فاعتقد انه بعض الحق في هذا ولكن
مقابل هذا الامر كيف ترى وزاره الدفاع
المصريه اخراج الامر وهذا حقها وهذا له
يعني
انا سالتك كيف يمكن ان يكون هناك طائره
اباتشي مصريه ترافقها طائره اخرى تنطلق من
قاعدتها وتستهدف مجموعه كما قالت البيانات
ارهابيه بهذه الصوره ولا يدري عنها
المتحدث او المعنيه بالتحدث عن القوات
المسلحه ويقول اه حدث انفجاران وسنذهب
للتحقق من هذا الامر هل هذا الامر معقول
اولا انا موافق استاذ محمود مما لاشك فيه
مفيش اي طائره ممكن تتحرك بدون علم اه
الاداره العامه القوات المسلحه وكان
المفروض يكون عند المتحدث الرسمي معلومه
بهذا ايه الخطا اللي حصل اه الحقيقه انا
ما عنديش معلومه ولكن اه ممكن يكون في بعض
اه ما يلام عليه الحدث من المتحدث العسكرى
سبب وانا معرفش ولكن
هذا يطرح هذا يطرح سؤالا بدوري ما الذي
يجعل المواطن المصري يصدق روايه هذه صادره
عن قياده القوات المسلحه كما قال اللواء
عبد الحميد عمران في هذا انخرطت في العمل
السياسي في اه ال ال اه السياسه المصريه
وصارت طرف من الاطراف الفاعله في السياسه
والله اذا كان هذا حضرتك بتتحدث على
استقبال المواطن المصري لما يقال فاحنا
بالنسبه للمواطن المصري ثقه عمياء وثقه
ثابته فيما يقول المتحدث الرسمي وفي وزاره
الدفاع وفي نفس التوقيت
مساحه الى ان وزاره الدفاع لها بعض ال
التوجهات وبعض التكنيك الذي يقام ما بينها
وبين ما يخرج من امل
ربما تنتظر لاسباب معينه اطراف اخرى حتى
تخرج ما لديها لها في هذا الامر
طب انا فاصل قصير مشاهدينا الاعزاء نناقش
بعده هذه القضيه نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش الجدل بشان مصدر الغاره
التي استهدفت يوم الجمعه من وصفوا بانهم
جهاديون في شبه جزيره سيناء والسؤال للواء
الدكتور عبد الحميد عمران اه سياده اللواء
اه ال اللغط الذي اثير حول شبهه التواطؤ
او شبهه التنسيق بين الجيشين المصري
والاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بعمليات تجريه على
ارض مصر بهذه الصوره الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يؤثر على صوره الجيش المصري لدى المواطن
المصري البسيط
اعتقد ان هذا انا احاول الجيش المصري
تجربه
بانه
يعني يقول انه هو من قام بهذه العمليه
وان الطائره المصريه من هاجمت هذه
المناسبه بتعبير اخر انا اعتقد وقد اكون
مخطئا ان الجيش المصري يحاول ان يشتري
العمليه من الجيش الاسرائيلي السيد ضربت
وهي اللي اللي اللي خلصت على منصه الاطلاق
والجيش المصري عنده مشكله داخليه في داخل
مصر وهو يتهم بانه غير ملتفت الى الحدود
وان كلهم ومدربه العدويه
والتعاون مع السيد تبقى المعاناه
الاسرائيليه فهذا كلام الجيش المصري لو
قال او صرح بانه
هو طائره اباتشي مصريه
الحقيقه جميع المشاكل بتاعت حيث تنسب اليه
بقصف هذه المنصه اثنين ما فيش تعاون بين
وبين الاسرائيليين في ثلاثه ال مفيش غيار
اصليه
ان تخترق المجال الجوي
كلها مكاسب الى وانا
تحضيريه وليست اي سلام اخر ان هذه العمليه
قامت بها طائره بدون طيار اسرائيليه وان
البيان او ال ال
ال ال ال القول المصري هو قول داخلي طيب
تعتقد ان استشعار المواطن المصري وجود خطر
على الحدود المصريه واه اه في ظل الظروف
السياسيه الراهنه يمكن ان يؤدي الى اتفاق
المصريين حول قياده القوات المسلحه ام الى
شك المصريين في كفاءه هذه القيادات على اه
اداره العمليه برمتها
والاحتمال الثاني هو الصحيح كمواطن عادي
انه يعني انت تركز جدا جدا في المواطنين
والصين المعتصمين والمتظاهرين سلميه وسائل
الناس اخترق الحدود لاطلاع العادي المواطن
المصري عاوزين الصوره عاوزين نقول كلام
غير واقعي يعني ايا كانت السبب او الدافع
احنا نقول ان ياخذ اخرى فنيه لكن لا اظن
ان في وجدان المواطن المصري الاحتمال
الثاني وحضرتك يعني ا طرح السؤال ذاته هو
على اللواء محمود
اولا يعني ما احترامي لكلام سياده اللواء
عبد الحميد و بياكد انه دائما عايز يعني ب
يؤكد ان الطائره كانت اسرائيليه وانا لا
ادري باي سنه يؤكد هذا هو
بيقول على الناحيه الثانيه ان هناك ادعاء
باي سنه حب تؤكد انها طائره اسرائيليه رغم
انه لم يخرج اي نوع من المستندات الرسميه
من الجانب الاسرائيلي اثنين اذا كان هذا
يؤثر على الجيش اضافيه هناك في الرابعه
وفي النهضه اه موضوعات سبق وقلت ان الجيش
المصري
السياسه العسكريه هي مؤسسه سياسيه عسكريه
بامتياز وهذا امر دولي ولكنها تتميز فيه
عندها القدره السياسيه التي اثبتتها واكدت
ها الشعب والشعب الداء الثقه الكامله في
هذا الامر نمره اثنين ما يحدث في سيناء
وما حدث في منطقه اه يعني ضد الارهاب وضد
المستهدفات التي خارج الحدود اكدت وعظمه
كان هناك تضارب في البيانات العمليه بهذا
الحجم العمليه بهذا الحجم كان هناك تضارب
في البيانات الصدر عنها من المتحدثين
المصريين وتنشر وسائل الاعلام الرسميه
المصريه بيانات وين فيها المتحدث العسكري
ثم يعود ف يؤكدها متحدث اخر وهكذا هل يمكن
ان يوفق في مساله التقدم في محاربه
الارهاب على ارض سيناء في ظل هذا الت ضرب
[موسيقى]
الله يا استاذ محمود يعني حتى انا بعرف
حضرتك ولكن مشوار طويل في الاعلام اه
حينما تخطئ مره او مرتين هذا لا يمكن ان
يعطيني سنه انا اقول انه حضرتك اه فقط
الثقه وانا فقط الثقه فيك اما كل في
العمليه السياسيه هذا يحدث هذا امر محتمل
لاسباب كثيره السياسه تحتمل مستهدفات
كثيره واحيانا يكون التضارب احدا وهذا امر
سياسي ولكن انا قلت لحضرتك انا من وجهه
نظري الشخصيه لا اتفق مع ما حدث من نوع من
الاختلاف ولا ادري سببه ولكنه قد ابدا لا
يصل الى نوع من اساس الثقه في القوات
المسلحه المصريه من شعبها ومن
نقول لهم كما هو وكما هو واقع سياسي عبد
الحميد عمران تعمد المصدر الامني
الاستشهاد برؤيه شهود العيان في للمروحيات
في موقع الغاره هذا رغم ان الانباء ظلت
تتردد طوال يوم امس ان ان الشهود راوا تلك
المروحيات عقب وقوع الغاره وليس قبلها او
اثنائها بينما قال شهود عيان اخرون ان
هناك بالفعل طائره بدون طيار هل يمكن ل
شاهد العيان او هل يمكن للمواطن على الارض
ان يميز الطائرات من بعضها البعض بمجرد
رؤيه العيب
حاجاتها الحصر بعض شهود العيان ذكروا ان
هناك طائرات مصريه اللي كانت موجوده ومشيت
وبعدها الطيار الطيار هجمه المنصه هناك
جهود اخرين هناك منه الشيخ المنيع اذا كان
بيروا انه فعلا طياره مواجهه بدون طيار هي
من قصف اطلاق الصواريخ وفي سياق روايته
بيقول ان احنا كل يوم بنشوف التيارات ال
المواجهه المعطيات حتى بنشوفها بايه طريقه
المصريه لكن في السياق لما يحدث كل يوم
قرارات المصريه الراحه بعد حادثه عشان
تشوف القصف
الولايات مختلفه وزاره
التخبط في ال ال
شكرا جزيلا سياده اللواء حميد عمران
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي واشكر كذلك
اه
اللواء محمود زاهر
الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه والاستراتيجيه
كان معنا من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لكما بهذا
مشاهدينا الاعزاء تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
تعالى في قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد
السلام عليكم
ام
[موسيقى]